um so i'm just having a guessing but i'm
guessing that you like anime
right yes it was it was just like a
feeling
just just like i just got that vibe i
don't know where i got it from
um so what kind of anime do you like um
i watch
a lot of anime uh i like really name
every animal
[Laughter]
oh you're an anime fan oh i like creamy
mommy
wow um that's not the first show that i
would have expected coming from your
mouth
i really like creamy mummy um what's
creamy mummy
it's like there's a girl called mummy
right and it's just creamy
yeah she's really creamy dog
yeah wow um recent animes i watch uh
boku no hero academia of course of
course
um
yeah oh like this is the list
i feel like i'm listening to like one of
those pv's
[Laughter]
[Music]
i i know i i can already tell that you
watch quite a fair bit
considering the fact that not only was
your first choice creamy mummy but also
the fact that you brought up milder
penguins
yeah yeah like psychopaths as well yeah
i love cycle
yeah i just kept nodding with that
penguin while i'm like yeah what is that
like this modern penguin drum is like oh
god
how do you explain that it's really hard
it's such a weird show
yeah yeah you've definitely seen clips
of it though probably yeah yeah
it's got a lot of animals yeah it's got
a lot of makes a lot of sense
i think i'm seeing a theme here do you
like
b stars
hell yeah dude of course you didn't
wait isn't there a movie called pets oh
yeah yeah okay
like the pixar
what were some of the anime that were
like the biggest influences for you to
like be a voice actress when you were a
kid i think bleach
was bleach wow wow i mean um yeah
because obviously like hitsuka was
um voiced by a lady and um
all the actors were like like like
so like i mean they were cool as [ __ ]
we've said a lot about bleach but uh i
mean everything about it was
cool you know especially it's a guy
right like romy park is such an amazing
voice yeah yeah yeah
you know like especially like i think
she did alphonse as well right
oh yeah no no she did um edward oh she
did yeah yeah yeah
yeah i would know that yeah yeah
and she's hanji from um attack on titan
that's right
oh yeah that's it yeah yeah she's like
wow
like yeah